ces images spectaculaires viennent de
Rostov en Russie il s'agit de centaines
de mercenaires du groupe paramilitaire
Wagner en cerclant le QG de l'armée
régulière russe de la ville et prenant
position dans des rues
vendredi soir evegaini Prigogine le
patron de Wagner est entré en Russie
avec ses hommes débutant une véritable
rébellion armée son but renversé le
commandement militaire russe dans un
message audio sur télégram trigogine a
dit vouloir une marche pour la justice
soulignant qu'il ne plaidait pas pour un
coup d'État militaire il s'est dit aussi
prêt à mourir seulement de ne pas
résister à ses 25000 combattants et à
inviter les militaires et même la
population russe à le rejoindre il
reproche notamment à l'armée russe
d'avoir bombardé des camps militaires de
Wagner à l'arrière du front en Ukraine
tuant selon lui un très grand nombre de
miliciens des accusations démenties par
le Kremlin dans la nuit Wagner a investi
Rostov sur le don ville d'1 million
d'habitants à l'extrême ouest de la
Russie près de la frontière ukrainienne
trigogine prétend même que les soldats
russes ont refusé de bombarder ces
hommes malgré les ordres de leur
état-major ils prétend aussi que Wagner
a détruit trois hélicoptères de l'armée
régulière une information encore non
vérifiée selon le ministère de la
Défense britannique Wagner se dirigerait
également vers le nord en direction de
Moscou des hommes se trouveraient à
voroneiges à mi-chemin entre Rostov sur
le don et la capitale de son côté le
ministère de la Défense russe appelle
les hommes de Wagner à abandonné
Prigogine affirmant qu'ils ont été
trompés et entraînés dans une aventure
criminelle un régime d'opération
antiterroriste a été instauré dans les
régions de Moscou et vorronnesh et
l'autoroute entre Moscou et Roscoff
longue de 300 km en partie coupée des
convois de l'armée régulière ont été
aperçus à Krasnodar et à lipette
respectivement à 1200 et 420 km au sud
de Moscou mais la situation critique n'a
pas empêché le Kremlin d'entreprendre de
nouvelles frappes en Ukraine les
défenses anti-aériennes sont entrés en
action et des explosions ont été
entendus à ni pro car Kift nikolife est
dans la capitale Kiev ou un immeuble de
24 étages a pris feu le président russe
Vladimir Poutine après plusieurs heures
de silence à réagi dans une allocution
télévisée
intérieur
des actions de combat sont menées depuis
ce matin près de voroneiges a annoncé
l'armée russe
de son côté le président tchétchène
ramzankadirov a annoncé avoir envoyé ses
hommes dans les zones de tension contre
la rébellion dans une vidéo sur télégram
samedi matin Prigogine demandait à
rencontrer le ministre de la Défense
Sergei et le chef d'état-major général
des armées Valérie guerracimov menaçant
de se rendre à Moscou s'il ne venait pas
à lui depuis des mois les tensions entre
le patron de Wagner et le commandement
militaire russe était croissante
trigogine se permettait même d'insulter
ouvertement Sergueï chouï qu'il accuse
de ne pas lui livrer d'armes et de
munitions en fin de matinée pris goji
une dénonçant une erreur de Vladimir
Poutine suite à son allocution a dit
qu'il ne se rendra pas à l'international
la présidente du Conseil italien Giorgia
Meloni a réagi estimant que les
événements en Russie montrent comment
l'agression de l'Ukraine déstabilise le
pays en France l'Élysée affirme
qu'Emmanuel Macron suit la situation de
près indiquant par ailleurs que le
président français reste concentré sur
l'aide à l'Ukraine
un choix
[Musique]